si la solidarité semble s'organiser en
france pour venir en aide à ceux qui
sont en première ligne comme les
soignants le personnel dans les magasins
alimentaires ou les éboueurs certains
comportements souvent guidé par la peur
laisse pour le moins à désirer certains
français n'arrive visiblement pas à
contrôler leurs phobies
à tel point que dans plusieurs endroits
du pays des comportements incroyable se
sont manifestés dans certains immeubles
des locataires ont carrément demandé à
leurs voisines infirmière de déménager
pour éviter de les contaminer sur les
réseaux sociaux ce mot circule depuis
plusieurs jours en sachant votre
profession est il possible pour notre
sécurité de ne pas toucher les portes
des parties communes ou peut-être dans
les prochains jours de loger ailleurs ne
prenez pas ça contre vous mais je pense
que moi même ainsi que les voisins se
sentiront plus en sécurité
d'autres reçoivent des messages
similaires toujours anonymes leur
demandant de garer leurs voitures plus
loin pour éviter de contaminer les
riverains vous êtes infirmière vous avez
plus de risque d'être contaminé par le
virus donc merci de ne pas vous garez
proche des autres mais plutôt dans un
garage la soignante concernés s'est
confié au journal la dépêche
j'ai l'impression d'être une pestiférée
alors que des personnes ne respectent
pas les règles du confinement
c'est inacceptable autre cas alors qu'un
propriétaire parisien avait proposé à
une aide-soignante d'occuper
gratuitement son logement à proximité
d'un hôpital
les copropriétaires de l'immeuble ont
refusé son installation sous prétexte
qu'elles pourraient contaminer les
parties communes alors des infirmières
rejetée par peur de la contamination
choquer ou pas choquer alors ça ça
incroyable cette histoire et on a avec
nous en exclusivité on a on à sophie
cayla sophie elle est folle ton histoire
franchement c'est quoi cette affaire là
j'ai choqué mais moi aussi je suis
choqué ouais mais qu'est ce que tu as
fait tes rester chez toi quand même ou
pas mais bien sûr bah oui et toi mais tu
regardes celle où les voisins ou quoi
mais là je pense que personne donc le
cph ou quoi mais tu t'entends des biens
avec eux avant moi mais jamais alors tu
as 24 ans ils te tuent retrouve charles
chez toi tu trouves un mot il vaut mieux
que tu quittes l'immeuble mais ils sont
sont taries points
et m'ont proposé de loger ailleurs mais
c'est faux
ouais franchement c'est incroyable rodez
dingue tu as vu cette histoire je suis
là t'as vu cette histoire c'est choquer
ou pas wes irin rey y moi je suis outrée
et c'est le mal
les filles un empêcheur à la vie je suis
choquée moi je dis petit je dis petit
parce que xala gdb petit lapin tu
devrais te mettre au milieu de la rue si
tu es un mec que je parle de toi et de
l'est à tout le monde qu'elle est là
sous merdes qui m'envient saas sur la
voiture elle est le sous genre qui s'est
permis de me mettre ça à moi j'essaye
toujours de sauver des vies
je ne supporte pas ce genre de connard
il faut le courage de le dire aux
familles le reste elle peut pas dire
autre mariage et nous nous les becs la
connais la télé adorent le dire
messieurs vous êtes des sous merdes
voilà c'est une histoire de fou
heureusement mais ce que sophie juste
juste est-ce que c'est pas le risque
justement si on géolocalise les gens qui
ont le sens c'est un autre débat à la
machine de balorre pas on parle de
sophie sophie bachiri donc tu arrives
étape c'est quoi ta par action tu as dit
quoi ma réaction
j'étais choquée donc au départ je suis
resté devant l'impôt et après en colère
après la répondu par amour ou un truc du
dow jones alors j'avais mis un mot parce
que ça sert à rien de rentrer là dedans
je reve nus que la personne de me voir
en face je peux comprendre l ai peur en
sachant la profession en fait je peux
pas comprendre qu'on en a assez de cette
de cette façon j'aurais préféré qu'il
vienne me voir et qu'on me pose des
questions je pense que les gens ont peur
parce que les gens
ça leur demande pas la tête je veux
l'entendre en fait je peux l'entendre
parce que tu écris manque d'informations
sur l'hygiène être je vibre j'aurais
préféré qu'il vienne me voir
oui bah oui on est oui civile comment
s'appelle la sophie shopi sophie pas
shopi soupire sa machu picchu min
les sous merdes kif et cognito te mettre
des papiers comme ça ils sont pas
capables ils vont pas être capable de
venir les lâches sont larges qui se
permettent de l'agir de tp pas tort tu
crois pas qu'il va avoir le courage de
venir apporter en essayant de parler il
te fait des dilutions ma belle
non mais bien sûr mais bien sûr mais
bien sûr après ça c'est j'aurais préféré
dès le départ après bien sûr que je
pense qu'elle viendra jamais que la
personne ne viendra jamais notre sueur
et j'en suis consciente mais c'est
dommage
en fait dans l'arrivée de sophie sophie
reste chez toi voilà fait attention à
toi surtout parce que voilà tu étais
infirmiers et il faut vraiment que tu
peux prendre soin de toi et je voulais
dire bravo pour ce que tu fais tu es
donc tu es dans quel hôpital d'accord ok
et batterie et fait ton boulot continue
à faire ton travail voilà il s'est tu te
détendre quand tu rentres chez toi n'ont
fait d'énormes bisous sophie et et tu
sais quoi et j'espère qu'il tint boutron
tous
après tout ça à faire une énorme fête
des voisins en tout cas il faut
continuer à rester chez soi à se
protéger pour toutes mes collègues qui
seuls les jours c'est important et ben
merci sophie d'un amour je te fais un
très gros bisous mais ouais c'est pas
avec ça je t'embrasse sophie merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci saut